yeah I mean when I when I hit 10 years
the pandemic hit so I was like I was
about to be on the road more than ever
so like I was booked more than ever that
Year everyone was about to blow up right
before the course
the pandemic held me back yeah my career
was taking off
no but I believe you
oh thank you thank you no I really
appreciate the words of affirmation
there
what's goody Hopper at the verse welcome
back to Hot Breath the show where you
learn comedy from the pros I am your
host comedian Joel Byers and our whole
goal here is to help cultivate the next
generation of great comics and our guest
today just recorded her first comedy
album after 10 years in the game and
giving up a career as a teacher
award-winning teacher in the inner
cities of Chicago she gave up two
master's degree to pursue this crazy
dream of comedy and now she is here
ladies and gentlemen hot Brethren and
sister in welcome to the show Amy
Schenker everyone welcome to the show
thank you thank you
welcome wow you almost made me regret
quitting teaching with what you you did
it for a long time you did like 13 years
yeah it was a whole career yeah day one
I was like
damn gotta get out of here yeah
yeah I walked in I was like oh what have
I done
and then you did it for 13 years yeah
because I couldn't admire I kept trying
to find other jobs but like uh
everyone was like will you work with
kids so how could we possibly use you I
was like well they're like technically
18. so they're not children
that's funny with the opposite of like
when usually when we as comedians do
comedy like first day we're like oh this
is it forever I'm ruining my life to
pursue comedy right and you can't yeah
well I guess you gave up a career did
you do comedy while you were a teacher
did they yeah it did I
um started uh I started comedy after my
brother's wedding because I gave like a
speech at his wedding and it was I had
so much fun it was like the 17th speech
my uncle was sleeping
um
and when I was done everyone was like
keep going I didn't write anything else
yeah but afterwards they're like you're
in the wrong field like you should be
doing this or this or that and I was
like yeah I mean maybe I'll try stand up
and I went back to Chicago where I lived
at the time and did a mic and was like I
don't know you know I did it once and
maybe
I'm like probably a week later I was
like maybe I'll do it again and so
um I would say I did it like once every
week or two weeks for a couple probably
six months and then was like if I'm
gonna do it like just do it and then I
just started going every night and
while you were a teacher you were going
every night yeah it was exhausting I was
like getting like four hours of sleep I
think I gained like 30 pounds just from
like not sleeping at all and working
basically I was getting up at like 6 30
in the morning working all day
um going home taking like an hour or two
nap going to mics going to shows staying
out you know schmoozing doing all that
and then napping and doing it all over
again so and this this isn't just like
you're not going in like washing dishes
you're like in charge of the youth yeah
of America yeah in the inner city of
Chicago yeah the city it was a high
school seniors basically and so um
they were eventually they caught they're
like what are you doing
some of them like saw me on on um the
internet so I was like hiding everything
and but I mean now honestly when I go
home still I quit teaching like eight
years ago probably and my kids still my
old students still come out to shows and
stuff oh that's cool yeah it's really
neat how long into teaching so I'm
trying to do the math so like how long I
into teaching did you do comedy before
you quit I did comedy for like three
years while I was teaching
yeah it was exhausting you were on that
that grind for like three years yeah
yeah and I don't think I could do it
again like that oh yeah for sure because
that was hard like just that yeah
because like you said I'm not just
walking into a job and like just
standing and washing dishes or whatever
it's like
I have 30 kids in my face at eight in
the morning just like what are we doing
I'm like oh my God I don't know man
what do we do yesterday we're watching a
movie again it's a movie day a lot of
movies
what what got you over the fear cause I
think a lot of people especially a lot
of people that listen to this have
thought about trying comedy but they
haven't taken the leap to actually get
on stage how did you like overcome that
inertia to like actually do it I well
one thing that people would say about me
when I started and I think that that
that teaching really did help yeah
um and especially where I taught because
like you couldn't really if you don't
have like classroom discipline and Stage
presence like you're not gonna be able
to control a classroom full of teenagers
and so like that part I kind of just
developed while teaching over the years
and so
like other Comics would be like look I'm
like listening to you and I you have my
attention but like you haven't there's
no jokes I don't know that I know that
part yet
like getting up wasn't
hard but but telling the jokes was like
impossible and I would just like and I
was an English teacher and so the for me
like writing was everything and I would
just write it my jokes word for word
verbatim and
um and try to kind of memorize it and go
up and just do that and uh
but I do there are like you know just
little tricks to the trade that when
you're
first starting out I guess would help
like how you who you delivered jokes to
you know and and um
getting the women on your side first
especially as a woman like you don't
want to go up on stage and like flirt
with the dudes because they're on dates
with women and then the women aren't
gonna laugh because they're like what
are you doing like flirting with this
guy that I'm on a date with and if the
women aren't laughing the men are gonna
stop laughing because they want to have
sex
right like I'm going home with her not
you yeah just like little things
delivering the joke like easy jokes to
like the harder laughers you know and
delivering like harder punch lines to
the easy laughers because laughter you
know catches so yeah it is contagious
yeah yeah just like little just little
things like that I think help out when
you're first starting just
yeah yeah I think preparing especially
early on for me preparing off stage
really helped when I got on stage to
have more confidence of like oh maybe if
this joke didn't hit I know what's next
I'm not like concussed because one joke
missed and I can move on to the next
thing and just keep going instead of
just crying basically
I also would write outs in my jokes like
places where I can just like naturally
bail on it oh interesting um because I I
tend to do more story form
and so if it's like not going well or
it's a new joke and I don't want to you
know ruin my confidence and what I think
it can be I'm like this crowd's not
feeling it I don't want to do it so I'll
just kind of naturally like bail in an
area that's that seems fine
and go on to something else so like
you'll you'll have a ju you'll know
Parts in within your stories that if
this doesn't get a laugh you do you have
a joke about it not working or like what
is the out are you just like yeah
sometimes I can't I sometimes I have a
joke if it's like going horribly yeah I
mean address that for sure but like
um just I tend to split my jokes up into
sections and so when I'm trying to
memorize a joke I'm more so memorized
like this section is about this this
sections about this and and then from
there take it and so like each section I
can kind of bail if I need to basically
like I'm writing a joke right now about
dinosaurs okay which is
I don't know it takes on a life of its
own every time I do it but it's like
just different parts to it like I'm
talking about
um
how they have sex in one part and I'm
talking about like
um how they uh the meteors in another
part and like a conversation that a
dinosaur has with his dinosaur mom and a
different part so it's it can just like
I can just end it at each of those parts
oh that's you know does that make sense
yeah yeah is that how you write because
like I would I started out with
one-liners and then like I've grown into
like larger bits but I would like to do
more storytelling it's something I don't
really have confidence in right yet yeah
but is that how you kind of piece them
together it's kind of like you know you
want to talk about this topic but you
kind of just tackle it one piece at a
time instead of this whole like long
thing no okay so the first time I go up
what I do if it's a story
um and my story is All stem from like
stuff that's just happened to me or my
family and so I just tell the story Bare
Bones I don't put jokes in it um at a
comedy show yeah you're just you're
willing to be like I'll stay up here and
just say this without any laughs just to
get the story 100 I'll just tell the
story exactly as it happened I don't amp
anything up really and I don't
um tag anything
um and I just tell the story and it's
pretty I mean I can be funny just
talking so I'm not like hugely worried
about it but
um then what I do is I go and listen to
see where like the laughs happen you
know naturally and then I build those up
and then where they don't happen at all
if it needs to be in there
um I just make it as as short as
possible if it's just information they
need to know just to understand the joke
you know and I can't figure out how to
make it funny I'll just like okay and
then but if it's and if it's something
that I'm like this could be funny I'll
just start working on it to make it a
little bit better but if it's just like
you know filler like I I cut it
so like what did you learn because when
you first started you like you're like
I'm performing but I'm not doing jokes
what did you learn about joke writing
that kind of unlocked like oh here's how
to write a joke or like what is your
approach to like oh this is how I can
actually make something funny like your
joke writing um I tend to do like if I
can't
one thing that does help me if I'm just
really really stuck is I make a list of
like 10 things
um
where I just like right I don't have any
rules to it like if I'm trying to find a
tag and I or a comparison let's say and
I just I just write a list of 10 things
because eventually one of those 10
things is gonna be the thing but
um not like not limiting myself to what
I write down just kind of allows my
brain to go in a lot of different places
that it wouldn't normally and so
um a crazy like let's say I'm do going
going back to the dinosaur thing like
let's say I'm doing something about
um
how dinosaurs have sex you know so and
I'm trying to think of like a third
thing that's funny because I I land on
dot on doggy style and I'm I'm like why
do we even call it doggy style like it
should be called Dinosaurs yeah and then
like and then I'm like what else would
we call it I would just like write a
list of 10 different things that we
could possibly call and like maybe get
something from that instead gotcha you
know yes
um okay also joke shopping with like
friends like we'll talk all the time you
know comic you can't have a serious
conference yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
can't even like talk about you're like a
dead dad without a comic clean like oh
yeah what about of course yeah yeah of
course so it's just everyone always
jokes but yeah I mean
sometimes it just comes to you randomly
there's also jokes that like you're just
not ready to to tell yet because you
don't have the skills you know I have
some jokes I'm definitely not there yet
or stories that I would like to develop
but I can't do it yet but I would
that's what keeps it exciting though
it's like we're always striving for more
and developing and getting better and
better yeah like the next thing the next
yeah I think that's that's a good note
of you're willing to put in the work of
it sometimes a joke just happens and
you're like oh thank you comedy world
but a lot of the times it is okay I have
an idea now I need to list 10 things
that may you're you're willing to put in
that work I guess maybe from your maybe
teaching or just English and writing
background of like I know to get to the
good stuff I'm gonna have to go through
20 terrible things to find it yeah
probably and I've I've you know gone so
many different directions with jokes so
many different times and and uh
the thing about like when you're first
starting out is it's like well it's it's
a different audience every time so how
do you know but it's like that's
probably it's kind of the same audience
though every time like it's people are
gonna laugh generally at the same stuff
you know so it's it's not really ever
going to be like the audience
like one audience that's like this was
perfect and the next one's gonna be like
this was horrible like yeah it's a lot
of averages I mean I've done I've done
shows at a club where eight o'clock
killed and I do the same set 10 o'clock
and it's like crickets you know or
they're just hammered yeah and I was too
young in the game to know how to like
navigate that I just had a set and I'm
like I'm doing this word for word both
shows and then 10 o'clock nothing but I
did the same thing word for word and
just kept going yeah you just pushed you
don't know anything better you just
because I was verbatim word for word for
a long time oh 100 written like and the
final product is word for word but I'm a
little more organic now but if I don't
if I don't write then like I'm let I
have less to say on stage if I'm trying
to quote right on stage if I'm not
writing off stage I have nothing to pull
from in general yeah I agree with that
like I can and even if I do like write
so much sometimes I still just go blank
and I'm like what the what was I saying
well like what was I gonna say about
this I totally don't and then I just go
in a crowd
which is so funny I just saw uh because
I'm based in Atlanta and I just saw a
comic because like Comics like Mark
Norman and like Sam Morel they'll do
like their set and then like crowd
workers like all right yell something
out and I'll do crowd work and then
that's their content so I saw like a
younger comic try this at a show where
he did his set and then he's like all
right someone yell a topic and they
yelled taxes and he couldn't find
anything funny about it and then he got
mad at the audience member but I could
tell he was trying to set up for like
his con his like his crowd work clip oh
man
everyone puts out crowd work clips now
because they don't want like their
materials stolen but it's like
just put out your material too like I
think you could do both
I think personally I think that because
who are you saving it for you know like
if you don't put it out someone else is
going to and it's not like I don't think
people are gonna remember as right and
like you could say you're saving it for
the album but they're still gonna buy
the album like they want to hear it all
together you know they want to hear the
final yeah piece and all of that
it's like when you recorded your album
how how long did it take you to develop
that material was this basically like 10
years leading up it's one through ten
yeah it's like because I I kind of split
it into
like three different parts basically
like if you look at my comedy it's
basically talks about the teaching
um like dating and then like family and
being Jewish and stuff like that so it's
like just boom boom boom and an every
joke I have will fall into one of those
categories and so
um I just took my favorites from those
categories and did like an hour of it
and then you had like uh I mean I know
when I did mine like I was in my hotel
room like just I was just rehearsing it
over and over and like how did you
prepare for it was it that yeah I mean I
was
um it was more just memorizing the
um the order that I wanted to do the
jokes in because I have some jokes that
I can't do up top because they don't
like if the audience doesn't know you
and I'm doing a joke about arming
teachers and shooting kids they're gonna
be like what the [__] that's wrong what
an icebreaker yeah
I'm like I was shot at too okay but you
can't say that after
because they're like I can see one
yeah especially where Utah I mean
goodness gracious yeah you live
Dangerous Minds like the movie Dangerous
Minds people say that a lot yeah it's a
little violent it was a lot of a lot of
breaking up fights and uh
I I would rather yeah I learned a lot I
don't know I worked in a group home for
like teenage boys and call and while I
was in college who's like their
alternative was um juvie and so I
learned like a lot of like discipline
techniques from that that I would use
during teaching that were probably legal
I would assume but um yeah
um we'll have to look at the statute of
limitations and then
Illinois
but you're you know your your window had
a bullet hole in it so I mean I did a
couple yeah yeah I wrap them up a little
bit this is no you had to like to just
to break up these fights because they
were just huge jumpings like I've never
I've seen one fight that was one-on-one
what made you what what made you like I
don't know like a better term but like
have a be so service minded like if
you're working with this group home and
then you're teaching at like a school
like this
honestly I kind of like
fall into these things almost like my my
best friend growing up Sarah Cashin
um was job hunting when we were in
college and she called what she thought
was a restaurant and it was a group home
and she's like oh yeah I'm just coming
into I wanted to apply for a job and
they're like oh this is like O'Connell
Youth Ranch is what it was called
and she's like I thought it was this
they're like no we're hiring too though
she calls me she's like come with me I'm
like okay wait three weeks both got jobs
that day
randomly and they never trained us
um at all we were we both worked in like
these separate homes they're like eight
boys living in each home and they were
like you know house parents and then we
would come in after classes and just
like help them with their homework and
cook dinner and like you know make sure
that they were you know functioning as
people and
it was
it was it was so Random like it was just
a weird thing and but it was fun I liked
doing it uh and I did learn a lot of
like discipline stuff then that they
really don't teach you in college
because how do you teach discipline
really and um
and as a teacher you can't really teach
unless you have classroom management and
so to have that I was coming from Kansas
going to the inner city of Chicago so it
was a very um different like switch you
know so those that job really
unknowingly like very much helped me so
and then with with
teaching where I taught I didn't really
want to teach in the suburbs because I
grew up in the suburbs like I don't
really need my teachers I didn't need
help from them and and I felt like I
could make more of an impact you know
elsewhere so that's why that's why I did
that but teaching as far as like going
into it my my um counselor in college
was like you know you have a lot of like
English credits you can either do
journalism or education I was like
journalism she's like education I was
like nope all right what glad to hear
that that's where the teacher origin
story is is like oh well I guess I will
might as well I was like my passion for
June no I didn't have that's what I was
waiting to hear it's like you know I've
always just had a heart for not no I
didn't I um
not at all I
what's goody hot breadthiverse if you're
loving this episode and all the other
awesome content you get here for free
then you are going to love our brand new
hot breath VIP list all you got to do to
join is go to
hotbreathpodcast.com VIP and you're
gonna get exclusive access to not just
pod cast but also other content like
unseen interviews merch drops discounts
giveaways and a lot more exciting things
and this is for everyone if you're an
aspiring or working comedian or just a
comedy fan that loves getting those
behind the scenes nuggets You're Gonna
Love what we have here at the new hot
breath VIP list so go to the link in the
description or join at
hotbreathpodcast.com VIP and I'll see
you there speaking of Comedy I've got a
shout out the network behind this show
big laugh comedy they have been killing
it in the Texas comedy scene producing
some of the biggest shows live and also
podcasts like the one you're watching
here and even bigger news big laugh is
hitting the road bringing their best
comedians and shows to a city like yours
so do yourself a favor join their VIP
newsletter and get exclusive access to
not just when they're coming to your
city but also even more fun content and
even in comedy news so all you got to do
is go to blcomedy.com
vip.hb or hit the link in the
description we'll see you there kids are
like fine
I've always worked with kids I was a
camp counselor for a long time yeah yeah
yeah one summer one oh yeah yeah for the
YMCA I did like I did like Jewish
Community Center camps and then we did I
did a camp Sabra which is in the Lake of
the Ozarks It's a sleep awake oh yeah
yeah yeah and we took our kids like
hiking on all over Colorado I lived in a
tent for three months I have not been
hiking since yeah or camping I'll never
do it because comedians who live in
tents so you know it prepared you for
that
it's real getting coffee yeah
that's that's really cool I love hearing
people who like some people start comedy
when they're young other when they're
later in life it's always interesting to
hear people's organ story into comedy
because you just never know yeah it's
like once you start though it's like
that's this is what I'm it's done it
just really does take over and it
changes your whole life it changes how
you look at situations how you approach
people how you go into things like
it is a little it's a little nuts
I can't think of another profession
really unless it's like being a hit man
that like really changes your life in
such a way that like everything you do
you're like outside of it you're really
it is still geared towards
somewhat of a comedic aspect you know I
wonder if that's the the hesitation why
a lot of people think about doing comedy
but never do maybe because maybe the
fear of stage is one aspect but maybe
the fear of like how it's going to
change their life and if they're willing
to actually start living that lifestyle
yeah I think that like the deeper you
get into it especially like going older
or if you have a family you know and
it's like
is this worth the sacrifice that because
that's a it's a huge sacrifice like
um
even like just dating I don't I don't
know like your dating life but like mine
is
um [__]
that sums it up yeah that's hilarious
yeah because you either have guys that
are like oh I'm as funny as you you're
like no you're not gross yeah you can't
be
um or you have guys that are Comics that
you're like on a date a comic or that
you know it's either a competition or
it's just like
the best are guys that are just like
supportive you know of of funny women
like that's cool like not but it's it's
rare
yeah I mean I'm I'm married and but we
we met in college but then when she
wanted to move to Atlanta I had to tell
her that like this is this is my life
like I'm literally out every night
basically so yeah if you're cool with
that I want to be transparent up front
that this it's literally like it
literally takes over your life so you
really have to find someone who
understands that and has like is
confident in that and doesn't feel
neglected when you do have to go do this
yeah Open Mic the good thing about your
about you is that like comedy is a lot
more like male dominated though and so
like you were going to a place where
there was just tons of dudes right right
but I'm also going to a place where
there's just tons of dudes yeah and
they're all funny and so to a guy that's
like maybe working a nine to five in
finance or something he's just like
you're I'm sorry you do whatever
oh yeah yeah
yeah that's I don't think about that
perspective because I am a dude right
yeah like oh yeah I I entered comedy as
a straight white dude the easiest entry
into it possible like they're like yeah
yeah for my wife she's like oh yeah that
makes sense yeah yeah that's yeah you
look the part yeah
but then you know when you're when
you're 13 years in and she's like oh so
you're going where how much does it pay
what is happening okay that's the one at
a certain point yeah when you do comedy
long enough that it is like all right
this is cool this is fun this is Art but
it's also a job so like at a certain
point you got to figure out that
intersection between show and business
you know yeah and that's like the part
that I think Comics are the worst at is
the business side because it's not fun
it's very and most of us have like the
worst add and it's like the focus for
the business side is is hard
and most of the time when I'm focusing
on the business side of it it's because
one of my comic friends is like do this
and we just do it together and I'll do
it with another one with another friend
you know because it's just like you
don't
it's that it's this whole entire
industry on the comic side is very like
self-motivated until you get help and so
but that that's basically what this show
I've interviewed over 400 comics on here
and it's basically is me like how did
you do that how can I do that yeah it's
I love and I want like Comics helping
comics and that's the whole intent of
the community around the show and it's
cool to hear like you said a comic
telling you no do this and you're like
oh cool I'll do that oh it worked cool
and then you tell another comic and
spread the word that way yeah even with
like stuff like oh taxes here's how I do
it you should do it like this and just
download this app and then just every
single time just click click click and
you're like oh okay oh yeah that seems
so much easier than what I've been doing
which is just taking receipts and
shoving them into this teddy bear
yeah
it's easier than tax evasion yeah was
that QuickBooks is that what you use
yeah self-employed yeah me too yeah it's
a game changer and then like the whole
like LLC stuff and all of that like it
just gets like when do you do it and
like everyone's like now you should have
done that years ago oh [__] okay yeah
yeah so you can start writing off stuff
exactly exactly so
yeah I just did my taxes
every every year I do them and I'm like
this is probably wrong
[Laughter]
yeah but the good thing yeah the
self-employed thing they'll tell you
like your audit risk and things like
that so like oh do they yeah because
I'll do the self-employed and then I'll
file it through Turbo Tax and it'll give
me like a reading of like what is your
audit level risk so my wife can sleep at
night basically yeah but maybe it's
different if I'm filing jointly I don't
know I should have an accountant on here
to just like break down you honestly
that would be a very because comedians I
mean half of what we get paid in is like
it's like dollars with Like Cocaine
residue on this right dollars and drink
tickets and it's like I can't but
chicken tenders is this a write-off you
know I don't know
how are you approaching like the
business side because you've been doing
it 10 years and that's it's kind of at a
point in my career I was like all right
10 years I released this comedy special
it's like I should start to take this
more seriously yeah that's kind of I'm
at your point I'm at that point right
now where I'm like I need a I need to
get a a bit of a firmer hold on this
part of it like the the
um the cash money sign
making it sustainable yeah yeah because
it is like
the way we get paid is crazy first of
all
always no sense yes no clue there's no
like
um just set
this is how Comics get paid every two
weeks you get this is always different
right and there's no and it's feaster
famine and so
um and I'm horrible with saving money
and so like if I get the money I'm like
who wants money
and then I'm like oh [__]
spamming time
brutal yeah I need a basically thank you
that'll be my afternoon oh yeah I don't
know yeah I mean when I when I hit 10
years the pandemic hit so I was like I
was about to be on the road more than
ever so like I was booked more than ever
that Year everyone was about to blow up
right before the course the pandemic
held me back and my career was taking
off
everyone said that
no but I believe you
thank you thank you now I really
appreciate the words of affirmation
there I was like does this sound like
I'm making fun no no I I didn't take it
as that okay good but I appreciate you
clarifying that can we cut that
we need to keep that that's the clip
that's the intro we need that is the
opening hook like I believe you you can
leave you
you start clapping you like turn to a
teacher again you've got this oh that
was not you're not like the rest oh no
no I was like you are all over them you
are all the same
except you you brought me lunch today
and I do appreciate it that's cool you
didn't hit on me I appreciate it no that
never
um was a conversation I got to have just
hot ass teachers
know what they would do what my students
would do is they wouldn't hit on me
normally but then when they would
graduate then they would be like just so
you know wow
or like on Instagram or Facebook it's
hilarious but bruh no my mom was a
teacher she taught an alternative school
so it was kids that got like expelled
from other schools do we go to this
school I think instead of juice yeah
yeah so it made me think of where you're
teaching and you what you did before
teaching of like all right what was the
origin there like the motivation
we used to have a um a juvie school like
in our school
yeah it was like a whole other school
within the school basically yeah and we
were just it
was a rough one that was a hard class
they would have uh they had like bars on
the windows and stuff the kids were
tough kids
what were the shows like you were doing
as well because in Chicago I mean I mean
I know in Atlanta I did a lot of like
the I've talked about this on the
podcast but I was white boy Joel I did a
lot of the hood rooms I would be the
only white person in the neighborhood
like that was a good question I well
Chicago's a I I think Chicago is one of
the most
for a big city it's one of those
segregated cities in America probably
you know still like you have and in
comedy you have in Chicago you have like
uh uh the white Comics are kind of North
Side black Comics more south side
um and then Latino Comics are more like
west side and so you do have three
separate scenes almost but and they're
trying to bring them together a lot more
my my whole goal when I started comedy
is that I wanted my material to work in
every single room in Chicago Without
Really changing the joke at all you know
yeah yeah and and I was able to get that
and so I was like all right if I can do
that then
then I know that I'm like my writing is
pretty good right so because if you're
able to reach like not just different
like uh you know black people white
people uh Latino people and from all
over the place but like people from like
different socioeconomic statuses like
people just from different backgrounds
growing up like all of that if they're
able to laugh at your stuff like I think
that's like you're doing it right
probably agreed what was one of your
like worst bombs have you ever gotten
booed or anything like that oh I got
booed I got food recently recently yeah
and I
but it was like it was so funny because
they were like just anti-semitic
basically oh my gosh I was doing I did
Jewish
it's uh this I said I was Jewish and
this guy was like an older guy goes oh
when's your train coming oh and I'm
going I think he thought I would just
like be like okay and I go I just
stopped the show I turn I go what did
you just say to me because like was
silent and I go did you just ask me when
my train I went straight into teaching
mom I was like did you just ask me when
my train was coming and he's like he
goes yeah I go I go oh because like to
take me back to the Holocaust in time
did you want me to go back to the to the
40s
he goes I didn't mean it like that and I
was like
are you autistic
no I go buddy it's one or the other oh
you tell me huh and um and his wife was
just like
it's like this is horrible and then at
the end of that set
another couple I go well I gotta go and
somebody this woman goes to hell oh my
God I go no sweetie how is the place
that uh Jews invented to keep you
Christians in check so I guess we gotta
tweak it and then her husband booed me
and go boo you [__] and then I walked
out the stage and I don't it you know it
didn't go great
well it sounds like but I feel like uh
it was it was the weakest boo it was
that it was the best boo situation I
could have gotten probably yeah I've had
like fights break out in the audience
when I've been on stage
[Music]
um
when I was like too new to be able to
handle it like I had no clue I just
heard like so much stuff going on in the
back of the room and I'm just like
and then
um yeah the
you're just still do it you're still
with your material you're just going
through and your friends are just like
because still new so they're just coming
to watch and they're excited and then
[__] happens you can't handle just doing
a you're in monologue mode you're just
standing there like yes you can't react
yeah pivot or anything
my very first
um bigger show it was
um this guy who runs a bunch of shows in
Chicago named Michael Kendo mikeyo and
he uh I was going I went to a show
because I was taking my students on a
field trip to to Europe and we needed to
do like huge fundraising and so he runs
these comedy shows that raise like
thousands of dollars and I was like oh
maybe I could do one of those and um
just hold not be on it but like just do
the fundraiser and so I went and I told
with a friend of mine a teacher friend
and I introduced myself told him what we
were doing and I mentioned that I just
started comedy like a few months ago and
he's like oh I'm gonna put you up and I
was like no God no it was like 500
people
I was like oh God and he and he's like
well think about it and I was like I
can't turn that I can't turn it down and
so I went up ate a huge dick and my
friend was videotaping on her phone she
was recording me and I kept I was like
send it to me send it to me and she's
like I will
so this day has not were any students in
my career no no no no no no but um yeah
but every I think that I don't think I
would still be doing comedy in all
honesty if it wasn't for for Mikey oh
because he kept like putting me up every
like couple like he'd be like come back
in three months come back in three
months and I would and he would put me
up in front of these huge crowds and I
would see what it could be and I was
like I love this you know otherwise
you're stuck at open mics for the first
like year two years and then it's like
brutal and so I'm
yeah he pretty much single-handedly kept
me in comedy and then when I started
getting booked more and more and it's
you know the best and now that room is
like one of my favorites to go up in
because it's just like a murder room
yeah yeah and you can handle it now yeah
yeah when did you take the leap to New
York I moved to New York after I quit
teaching
um oh I moved with uh Jeff Sheen and
Josh Johnson oh great yeah yeah and um
we all lived together for like three
three years probably
um in New York yeah in like a studio or
like was it no and like uh it was like a
just a like a two bedroom and then we
put a wall up and you know
um just uh we're poor that's what I mean
I've had comic friends who moved to New
York and it was like oh yeah one room
and they just put up like a sheet and
it's like four Comics oh I think that
the next place that uh at least one of
those guys moves to that's not Josh
Johnson was um
for a while yeah
like what are you guys doing they're
like we don't know
you have to sacrifice for the game yeah
a wall
the whole wall
that's crazy stability okay yeah New
York is definitely a much different
uh animal I think than than coming up in
Chicago for sure yeah because Chicago is
like a Party City like comedy is like
you do comedy you all go to the mics and
then you hang afterwards and it's just
fun right and in New York it's like you
you when you're first starting there
you're going to mics and just jumping
jumping jumping jumping and then you're
exhausted and going home or like you're
going to shows then you have another
spot another spot another spot nobody
hangs as much because they're working so
much harder but um and it's just such a
a bigger scene you know so it's
definitely it was a it was a
a definite wake up
I would say yeah how'd you get going in
the scene I mean did you move with like
leads on shows or was this like a leap
of faith yeah kind of a little bit of
leads and just like you know
um we knew I I had been going to New
York
um a little bit and so I knew some
people there and I think that's
important like any scene that you're
thinking about moving to like I would go
at least like
at least like five times probably before
you make that leap and I would be
checking out other scenes also like I
was debating between LA and New York and
it just came down to like I just
happened to like I had just been making
out with a lot more guys in New York and
L.A and I was like I'll tell you good
stage time oh okay no not even they
weren't even Comics but I was like I
think that I just feel better
but you know it's that life balance of
course and I no longer have that was
important yeah
so how did how did you end up in Austin
like are you visiting right now is that
yeah I visit I kind of split my time
during the pandemic like I know I was in
in Brooklyn in my apartment for like a
year and I was just like this is
too much like it was just a lot and so I
bought a car oh and the creek in the
cave which is in Austin now used to be
in New York and so in LIC Long Island
City and uh they closed there opened
here and the owners of Rebecca China is
a is a good friend of mine and so I was
like oh I'll just come down and hang for
a little bit and I just I liked it here
you know I grew up in in Kansas City and
so it's kind of like the same Vibe a
little bit and it's just it's easier to
live here
and um so I just I was spending more
time here but I was splitting I'm gonna
be spending a lot more time though in
New York now that I've done my album and
so oh okay so you're going back up there
yeah yeah and I'm hoping to do it like
maybe like 25.75 or I don't know we'll
see but I do I do really like Austin
this the scene is it's growing and it's
really supportive and you know there's
like different like
nooks and crannies in it that are that
are pretty cool so but New York I guess
is where you can really like Forge get a
lot of stage time and really and like
find your careers you know maybe a
little bit like through more than just
stand up like with writing and stuff
like that too and so
we'll see I don't know is that what you
want to do is get more into the writing
side of things too I love Yeah I want to
write for either my own show or I would
love to write for for a show and then uh
and do stand up at night like that's my
dream for sure yeah
yeah what would be the show you would
want to write for the most be on your
own beyond my own
good question then
oh okay that's cool I was trying to get
a feel for yeah I like like the type of
writing I like doing would be like
Archer type of writing fun okay yeah
writing is such I mean it's such a
muscle and like writing stand-up is one
thing but then writing scripts and all
of that is like a whole other muscle
development and all of that yeah it's a
whole other skill set that it's
it I guess writing's not what I've
learned from interviewing so many people
out writing is like it's no it's not fun
for anyone like everyone has like the
force themselves to write it's just the
the successful people like the ones that
it's their job are the ones that
actually like force themselves to do it
yeah like they take it as a job before
it's even their job like it's their job
to get the job you know and so yeah and
I definitely need to
focus more on that part of it too
because I feel like I've been like
slacking lately just writing just
focusing on the joke part of this so but
you were doing the album like yeah right
Mountain type deals right trying to give
you a little room there of like you know
you're killing it basically so we all on
our heads could be like I could be doing
more and this and that right like you
know yeah well I think it's like when
the money is coming in it's like yeah
I'm doing a lot but when the money's not
you're like what am I doing sure oh
instantly yeah instantly like oh I
figured it out I'm on top of the world
oh my I hate myself I'm going back to
Enterprise Rent A Car this is just the
worst yeah yeah do you write every day
or like what's your discipline there I
I probably do write every day but I
don't like go to the coffee shop at 3
P.M and stay for until five and you know
yeah
I kind of write before mics or before
shows are all right
um
like if I'm if I run into some friends
or I'll plan a look a little writing
session with friends or something but
um
I I probably sit down and write by
myself like twice a week right before
shows probably two or three times a week
and then like the rest just like joke
shopping oh yeah okay yeah so you're
chipping away at it then yeah yeah for
sure I find I find most of mine isn't
even like trying to a lot of times I end
up just like journaling I'm just like
forced myself to sit down and do
something and just actually like write
yeah and then sometimes the momentum
will take me into developing jokes or
whatnot sometimes like I Journal cool
that's enough and it just kind of keeps
the ritual I guess yeah I mean because
there are times when you're just like I
don't I don't have it in me to
like joke or or write about jokes today
like I'm in such a bad mood you know
whatever it is that you're just like
like whatever yeah but yeah I do
I do try I think writing like the the
like script style stuff is much is much
harder for me to get into though I will
say that oh it seems so daunting it is
yeah because it's like this huge thing
where it's like when it's your joke it's
like that's the end of the joke yeah
yeah
if it doesn't work on stage you can
tweak it or whatnot but with a script
it's like you have to do this whole
thing and then you figure out the
response and then what you need to like
refine and stuff yeah and it just gets
to be yeah daunting it's a lot
but you're gonna have your own show
That's so exciting I don't know maybe oh
I was speaking it into yes we are gonna
right yeah should I not I am going to
have you you're so like affirming on me
so I was like I want to be a firm you
are going to have thank you I would I
was like oh he misunderstood what I said
people are gonna be like you lying
bill would you want it to be an
animation like an Archer what would you
want it to be uh I think I have like an
idea for that and then I have like I
wrote like this I wrote a teaching
um pilot actually just just stemming
from my first year of teaching and how
Wild it was because it was just insane
and so I just wrote like a pilot for
that which I would like to
develop but there's so many teaching
shows that are out right now and I like
Abbott Elementary's out which now I'm
like phenomenal right and so good it's
just like you kind of gotta
I don't know move on to the next thing
or something or maybe go back to that
part later
I don't know okay but the other thing is
like your following has to be huge too
for them to start paying attention to
you I'm not really sure that part of
like the the industry
um where they're like
we here's what I've been told a couple
times but it's pre-pandemic but I've
been told like we love the script or we
love this we love that but like she
uh nobody knows who she is yet so like
what do you want us to do with her like
yeah can you do that
all right
yeah and so it's like interesting so I'm
not really sure
um how to like break into that side of
it yet Beyond just like doing it
yourself I get like yeah yourself which
is like
yeah you're like your following needs to
be big or your bank account needs to
just be empty I guess basically which um
I have one of those things so we're on
the right track we're halfway there
that's perfect well cool well I mean
thank you so much for doing this yeah
for sure thank you I'm so excited to
have you on here at this point in your
career where you just record an album
and you're really like you're hitting
that next chapter of your career so
that's my favorite part about this show
is getting to interview people on the
ascent you know you've already done a
lot of cool things but just the ascent
is really cool we can look back on this
and do another one and be like remember
when you said
I'll be the counselor maybe I could be
the school counselor oh yeah yeah I mean
it is I'm just like the boyish yeah
you're just gonna get run over yeah
for sure well where um what is there
anything you'd like to promote or like
anything else I mean my album will be
coming out in July so I'm really excited
for that I don't know what I'm gonna
call it yet but it's by Amy Schenker
it's so exciting yeah I mean you can
find me on social media at Amy Shanker
everywhere and um
that's it I'm in Austin when does this
come out I don't know yet a couple weeks
okay I'm in New York you'll be back in
New York yeah yeah doing shows and such
yeah I'll be in New York I'm gonna be
um
I'm pretty excited to go spend some some
time there because I haven't done that
in a minute so
hopefully it'll be you know I won't fall
down the subway stairs again I mean any
any um friend I've had that moved to New
York has had like a New York moment of
like crying on the Subway or something
oh yeah if you haven't cried in New York
like you're not a New Yorker but I fell
down the stairs though once and it was
like such a slow fall and one of my
roommates was just behind me not helping
me and just I would just move and fall
down one step and then he'd just take a
step you're a dick dude
not help me up but just like watch me
just go don't don't
sound like a good friend yeah he's a
horrible person
so is that the con is that the grind in
New York right now as you're just doing
as many shows as possible is that yeah
basically I'm writing I'm gonna be I
think starting a podcast pretty soon
which I'm excited about because there's
not enough and then definitely um
definitely well that's why I've been
doing this for six years right and yours
is the only one I've heard of so that's
perfect you know we made it yeah
so that yeah and then um I think I want
to start a show there stemming from an
old podcast that I had called the most
expensive joke which is oh yeah didn't
you do this here I yeah I did it here's
the show Once and
um just to like kind of see how it goes
with a tone Bell um Rojo Perez yeah it
was so fun
um but it's about the situation that
cost you like the most in life whether
it's like mine is being arrested at
LaGuardia and and um it cost me a lot of
money but
um but like people like divorce or like
therapy or relationships some guy
started like a forest fire like there's
just been like tons of different stories
and we've had great comics on and I want
to I think I want to start it as like
maybe a live podcast show yeah I think
it would be great pretty fun yeah yeah
okay so yeah there's some stuff to
please do I need anyone listening we
need to count a billabuddies out there
to DM you and be like have you started
that yet that's a great idea I do need
that yeah I need that motivation
um extrinsically because I don't I'll
just be like
well some of my favorite things to do in
this is when a guest reaches out after
their Show's released and is like wow
people like reached out and they like
had questions and they were grateful for
like the information I shared so I'm
hoping people do that with this one
people listening I would love that I
really would because it's um you know
it's good to get a sense of of
if people do want to hear about that
stuff you know before you're like I'm
gonna dedicate so much time to this and
then like it's just a bust it's like all
right yeah well we'll keep an eye out
for it thank you thank you is there is
there any uh closing advice for young
Comics out there you'd like to share
um yes
I would say that if your heart's not in
it [__] quit
for short but if your heart isn't it
um stop stalling and put everything you
have in it and just go for it like what
are you doing you know because time goes
pretty fast Boom Amy Schenker thanks for
being a hot breath okay thank you yeah